welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of boba fett episode 5 which leaves
behind nearly everything we've been
talking about boba fett and his boba
baths slipping off that book jacket to
reveal this as one horny chapter amanda
hey look everyone it's mando
[Music]
i mean not that i'm complaining this
episode was packed with star wars easter
eggs lore and really cool visual details
that you might have missed so i'm gonna
break it all down ready to have your
mind blown we opened in a clatunion meat
packing plant those meat carcasses
aren't identified but in the concept art
in the closing credits they look like
nerf heads nerfs in addition to the
sickest way to spend saturday afternoon
are herd animals first mentioned in
empire strikes back half-witted
scruffy-looking nerf herder the ironic
butchery in a butcher shop the bounty's
blood to later dripping on the kill
floor beside that dripping meat is a
classic gangland trope from frankie
carbone and the meat truck and good
fellas to the first episode of the
sopranos when christopher whacks a meal
in cetane's butchery this chill
temperature also returns denjarin to his
bounty in the pilot episode on the icy
planet of pagadon which he calls back
directly i can bring you in warm or i
can bring you in cold i can bring you in
warm
or i can bring you in cold but our first
look at mando shows only his silhouette
through the greasy flaps framed so that
his best gar spear is visible telling us
that this is not boba fett it's not a
leader but still a hunter and of course
his entrance is announced with ludwig
jordson's flute theme for the character
his bounty is kabba baez played by stunt
actor artisteer redpor who also works on
obi-wan kenobi mando has a tracking fob
and the bounty puck translates to wanted
in auravesh listing his bounty as 9830
credits significantly more than the 7
300 wanted for that mithral in mando
episode 1. bais pretends to be just
another platoonian but they designed him
with distinctive piercings on his nose
and his jowl to make him unmistakable
from that puck now the moment mando
ignites a dark saber his arm lowers
slightly its weight already noticeable
and as he fights them with it the saber
drags along the ground sloppily slices
nearby meat and mando burns his own leg
this sets up the true conflict for this
episode danjarin vs his own darksaber
you are fighting against the blade the
legendary figure who forged this weapon
tar vizla was both a jedi and
mandalorian but din jarrah now feels
like neither mando did win that saber
rightfully according to their creed
besting moff gideon and a duel yet still
the weapon weighs awkwardly in his hands
a cursed artifact that the armorer
believes led to the genocide of their
people and i think that is what has him
spooked that leaving grogu in the hands
of the sorcerers who build and wield
these unwieldy weapons might have been a
mistake the episode title is introduced
by fusing the boba fett music with the
flute of the mandalorian theme
[Music]
mando visits this amazingly designed
curved ribbon urban landscape ring city
lit by a nearby star that casts a moving
shadow on itself to simulate day and
night i just love the production design
alternating patches of day and night on
that ring moving so fast hope you get
blackout curtains because it's gonna be
hard to get eight hours of sleep the
whole design of the city evokes other
sci-fi space communities like elysium
interstellar halo 3 larry knives novel
ring world and in classic star wars
fashion we start in super close up on
the space structure before we even know
what it is and actually our very first
glimpse of it shows the dark unlit back
side of it the industrial sub strata
this is the area used as the home to the
survivors of denjarin's mandalorian clan
you might actually be able to see the
exact ledge where mando finds the
armorer later director bryce dallas
howard pulls off one of the most
impressive long takes we've ever seen in
star wars a full two minutes and 18
seconds without cutting tracking mando
into the turbolift through the party
into the guildmaster's room then back
through the party then down the turbo
lift to a lower level than he was before
and they didn't mask any cuts in this it
was truly done practically and assuming
they didn't build this entire building
and didn't do all of this in that
lightbox thing they have it looks like
they used the time that he spent in the
lift to rotate him 90 degrees past a
green screen or led background to the
party set and then when he went back in
the lift they rotate him again having
used all that time to change out the
original set to a lower level set that
they must have rolled in this is some
true david copperfield and i love
it because it makes this all feel so
immersive it's the same kind of
practical magic we sense on disney's
rise of the resistance like wait how did
we get in this room did did we roll i
think we rolled or we pivoted what are
the others but most importantly this
long take reveals the way mando's
dealing with the pain of his dark saber
wound because notice whenever he has to
share a crowded space he hides his limp
and stifles his winces until finally
when he's alone on that lift he releases
his pain
[Music]
now as anyone in these awesome fictional
universes could tell you crashing around
in crazy vehicles and shooting stuff
with our friends is fun and in the super
fun five versus five shooter mobile game
tacticool you get to do a lot of
blasting play with 20 million players
around the world in this award-winning
game name the best competitive game by
google play download the game right now
by clicking the link in the description
or scanning the qr code on screen use
the promo code tacti to get some great
in-game bonuses 50 jason shards an rpg
and 50 000 silver there's multiple
gameplay modes including battle royale
and zombie survival there's lots of
weapons to use in 28 different operators
to unlock drive cars with online
teammates shoot from windows break
fences or get stuck in a swamp it's
great playing with live players to see
what your opponent does your success
depends on team play and smart tactics
it's cool that each character has their
own unique skills they even have a
character who walks around with a
four-barreled grenade launcher like
schwarzenegger and commando so support
new rockstars by downloading tacticool
from the link in the description or the
qr code on screen use promo code tactide
and get 50 jason shards an rpg and 50
000 silver now he shared that looked
initially with a kaskadag and in the
party he passed a three-eyed gran also a
charger fan and greets the issue tib
guild master who's voiced by helen
sadler who has voiced several star wars
animated characters including jen erso
on battlefront also sitting at the table
as a quarren now down in the below
levels he follows all these hidden
glyphs literally pointing this is the
way to a final glyph in the shape of a
mythosaur skull that is the beast
defeated by mandalore the first and
painted on boba fett's armor as well he
finds the armorer in the substrata below
meditating with her hammer and tongs
crossed on her chest always seen with
these because these are her most sacred
tools we also see her later wielding
these as weapons while sparring against
the darksaber she uses these both to
literally rebuild her people and their
armor but also to metaphorically rebuild
their spirit paz visla attends to him i
didn't know if i would ever see you
again
thank you for
saving me on nevar paz of course is
played by john farrow himself a former
rival to denjar and angry over his
accepting stolen as payment and a
descendant of house wiesla in the death
watch in which his father priebus love
was first seen wielding the dark saber
as the heir to tarvisla who forged this
saber paz applies some back to spray to
the burn a more concentrated version of
the fluid in boba's healing tank and
then mando reveals the dark saber
this
whistler
bring it to me
i love the music switching to cryptic
strings as paz recognizes this weapon
the armorer calls him by his full name
as if to underline his ancestral claim
to it and paz cradles this hilt
reverently and then as the armorer
twists the blade in her hand i like how
you can see its flatness making it
disappear from view as she twists it a
contrast to the pole shape of most other
lightsabers and then the armor reminds
us of the darksaber succession rule if
it is won by creed in battle it is said
one warrior will defeat 20 and the
multitudes will fall before it
if however it is not one in combat and
falls into the hands of the undeserving
it will be a curse unto the nation
mandalore will be laid to waste and its
people scattered to the four winds and
as the armorer talks about the history
of tarabisla the frame places this
descendant pause directly center so that
when the armorer hands back the dark
saber it passes directly in front of him
and then the transition wipe closes on
him specifically mando tells paz that he
took the lightsaber from moff gideon
whom he didn't kill but he was sent off
to the new republic for interrogation
and he will face justice for his crimes
now the new republic tribunal would be
located around chandrila but at this
point in history the new republic
government struggled to organize with
many political rivals to lay organa that
led to her resignation and formation of
the resistance so yeah who knows if moth
gideon will truly face real justice the
armorer says the songs of ian's past
foretold of the mythosaur rising up to
herald a new age of mandalore sadly it
only exists in legends yes upon meta
wording here only existing legends
referring to expanded universe lore that
is no longer considered canon however
with the mandalorian in the book of boba
fett filoni favreau rodriguez these guys
have really made it a mission to restore
legends elements as official backstory
once more so this mythisar legend is as
true as anything else in star wars mando
says his best guard spear was given to
him by a jedi referring to ahsoka tano
last season but ahsoka actually got it
from morgan l smith who serves grand
admiral thrawn thrawn i'm wondering may
have been the one to order the bombing
of mandalore in the purge of its best
guard thus why the armorer melting it
down from a weapon back to armor is what
triggers the flashback to those events
in this episode but first they talk some
about bo katan crees bo katan is a
cautionary tale she once laid claim to
rule mandalore based purely on blood and
the sword you now possess
but it was gifted to her and not one by
creed bocaton crees was born of a mighty
house but they lost sight of the way her
rule ended in tragedy they lost their
way and we lost our world now remind you
that bogatan was given the darksaber by
sabine wren in rebels and at that time
it was really presented as a solemn
homecoming of a sacred sword to
mandalore's native daughter the heiress
of the mandalorian people but now the
armor is suggesting that that false
succession triggered a curse that doomed
all of mandalore and the glowing
spearhead bisects the mandalorian moon
of concordia in this cross dissolve in
the animated series concordia was the
refuge of the death watch which in live
action became the watch group of the
mandalorians that we are now with and
finally we see the great purge in the
night of a thousand tears that maf
gideon mentioned in the season one
finale with a fleet of tie bombers
wrecking the surface of mandalore
emitting nuclear-sized mushroom clouds
that dome structure that blows up is an
entire mandalorian city which they
encase inside of massive domes like this
as that flame wall rushes toward us in
the foreground is a mandalorian helmet
discarded on the ground imperial probe
droids and kx enforcer droids these are
the kind k2so was in rogue one comb
these ruins where more corpses and
discarded helmets wait for plundering
it's clear that they did not send human
soldiers into this mess because the
conditions were so toxic and of course
all the imagery here seems directly
inspired by james cameron's apocalyptic
future imagery and t2 judgment day now
boba fett referred to this last season
mandalore the empire turned that planet
to glass but boca ton also refuted this
exact narrative that planet is cursed
anyone who goes there dies
once the empire knew they couldn't
control it they made sure no one else
could either
don't believe everything you hear now
it's not clear if the armorer is casting
all of this as a causality of a dark
saber curse or just suggesting the
improper succession was a reflection of
poketon's poor leadership that
eventually led to this but either way
everything in star wars comes from a
certain point of view and i think it's
fair to assume that not everything on
mandalore was destroyed and this all
might have been exaggerated by imp
propaganda in the midst of rival clans
like this armorer might have her own
agenda to hyperbolize that destruction
and blame bo katan for it manu asks the
armorer to forge something for grogu in
order to master the ways of the force
jedi must forego all attachment that is
the opposite of our creed
loyalty and solidarity are the way now
ahsoka did warn mando about this his
attachment to you makes him vulnerable
to his fears i've seen what such
feelings can do to a fully trained jedi
knight
to the best of us so what changed after
mando handed off grogu to luke skywalker
or jedi training i think the darksaber
does carry with it a kind of mysticism
if not a genocidal curse at least a
self-inflicting burden that has made
mando second guess the wisdom of the
weirdos who wield these things they
forged the spear into what looks like
chainmail armor for grogu knee thrill
which does make sense for a child that
mando won't know the exact size of or
how large they'll grow the armorer ties
it into a bundle that adorably takes the
shape of grogu's head now later they
spare
yeah those are the mandola words for one
two three and four and all this
parallels kanan jairus training sabine
and rebels when she was learning to use
the dark saber both the counting and the
way that the dark savers wait depends on
the connection with you the blade feels
lighter
you're connecting with it it's becoming
a part of you finally amanda's able to
block a hit and i love how her best
guard tools brighten up but they do not
bend making an interesting sound there
feel it
you are too weak to fight the dark saver
it will win if you fight against it yeah
that metal is vibrating to a higher and
higher pitch as if the dark saber itself
is hissing in rage so paz vasila makes a
claim for the dark saber in the tool
duel both removing their jet packs so
that now if either of them fall it's
game over man paz uses his vibroblade
the weapon that came up in their fight
in season one aiming it straight for
mando's shoulder at first but mando
destroys both the blade and pauses
shield with one swipe in the dark saber
but paz gets the upper hand paint has
brought this blade back to my clan and
our fate will end yours yeah paz
struggles with this weight even more
than mando did in his pose as he holds
it definitely evokes the macho
spaceball's energy of these kind of
duels but mando defeats him by using the
same move that paz initially used in
this fight vibro blade to the gaps in
the armor mando goes for the death by a
thousand cuts method and it works but
only because paz refuses to let go of
the darksaber to defend himself he
fought the darksaber not his opponent
and i like how each time nanostabs them
you can hear a little flute of the
mandalorian theme coming in
but despite his victory mando must
confess that he did once take off his
helmet leading to him getting shunned
unless he is able to attune according to
creed one may only be redeemed in the
living waters beneath the mines of
mandalore these living waters of
mandalore are yet another new piece of
star wars lore another example of how
this series expands mysticism beyond
jedi dogma the tuscans have a nose
lizard that takes you on trippy quest to
a mystical gaffey tree the mandalorians
have this underground spring that
presumably feeds their best scar minds
in both cases an element of nature from
which they derive their sacred weaponry
in armor and renewing their souls i
believe that all of these religions are
really just different interpretations of
the same force as mando departs with his
jetpack and darksaber the armorer keeps
her back to him tools in hand just as
she was when he first arrived so mando
tries to board a commercial starliner
passing a guy wearing the same white
range trooper coat that we saw in solo a
star wars story but he stopped by a
security droid the same rx series droid
who deals cards in garcia whips
sanctuary and originally the series
designed for disney star tours ride now
djing and ogus cantina and galaxy's edge
mando has to unload his blaster all of
his whistling birds his bandolier shells
the vibra blade detonator charges
grappling wire and the dark saber all
the things we've seen them used to kill
people on the trip a rodian kid waves at
him clearly reminding mando of grogu
because he pulls out that grogu shaped
bundle listen to the music
[Music]
yes that is the grogu theme from the
exact scene where mando learned his name
kroger
and they land on tatooine
on behalf of all our crew thank you for
traveling
at travel yeah i like how the departure
droid from the ring city functioned fine
but the arrival droid of tatooine is all
glitchy kind of like when you land in
laguardia and the delta agent pukes on
you in the shot of pelimoto a beady
droid hobbles out this is the same kind
of droid as bd1 branded calcustus and
jedi fall in order i even like how his
foot drags injured just like how beatty
once foot gets damaged in the game but a
womp rat grabs it
these are the rodents luke bragged about
shooting placed a bullseye womp rats in
my t16 back home they're not much bigger
than two meters her other droids include
her pit droids a wed treadwell repair
droid originally from a deleted scene in
the 1977 film and our good friend r5d4
the same astromech with the busted
motivator that luke and uncle owen
almost bought in the original film we
saw pelly with most of these cameo in
episode three remember luke did say womp
rats aren't much bigger than two meters
remind us that these things can still
get pretty big and five foot one amy
sedaris is definitely at risk
yeah pelimoto gets pulled away as if a
velociraptor's eating her which kind of
feels like bryce alice howard throwing a
nod to her jurassic park franchise
mandos saves her and she greets him hey
look everyone it's mando
[Music]
yeah they all groan because mando hates
droids and the first time we saw these
guys he shot at them and pelly reveals
her replacement ship an n1 starfighter
from the royal guard of naboo seen in
phantom menace now it's not exactly the
fighter that anakin piloted because that
futhark language on the side of the
cockpit is different the letters on this
one translate to p-h-e
it's gibberish it's gibberish i mean
either you see to spell out something
every time or don't she finds a nest of
scurriers meaning she literally hadn't
touched these scraps for weeks and she
says this fighter will be faster than a
father referencing the racing animals on
the tracks of kanto bite seen in the
last jedi pelley talks about her love
life dated a jowl for a while they're
quite furry hurry free
a lot of issues that's okay i'm working
on me right now hurry up oh my god we
need those peli flashback does what
inner scars is she now trying to heal
from
now the gank droid they use to power the
ship is marked with aurabesh letters db
i assume for dim balls based on the way
mando talks about his comp link shaft
later
there's a gong skunk jack the jawas
bring them a cryogenic density
combustion booster which is the same
prop as the poll that han solo tried to
use as a brace in the trash compactor in
the death star after initially
intimidating the droids mando finally
credits bd thanks little guy
and pele says the jawas could find a
scud in a krill pond scud was actually
the name of jabba the hutt's henchmen in
the 70s comics krill are the blue
crustaceans that we saw in sorghum in
mandalorian season one now the fact that
they're using stolen pike tech could
potentially set up pele's shop to get in
trouble with the pikes as mando and boba
face the pikes in the season pikes do
not mess around ever since they've been
moving spice to the system everything's
gone to hell everyone's afraid of them
and law enforcement won't even go near
them and by law enforcement i assume she
means the new republic x-wing pilots if
the new republic won't prosecute the
bikes it's just a troubling sign heading
into this war the completed fighter
looks sick with its chrome colors it's
just a perfect metaphor for what dave
filoni has been doing with these series
rebuilding components from the prequels
back up by hand to prove how beneath the
surface there was some really cool
hardware there mando asks what happened
to the droid port i hogged it out you
know i figured with your disposition
you'd want to forgo the astromech
hey watch your language around the
customers yeah i like how r5 reacts to
being called useless but now if you
think about it this droid port makes a
perfect jump seat for grogu he test
drives it through the same rock
formations from the pod racing track in
episode one
eric she's fast yes of course dank
ferric the star wars swear and he
continues through beggar's canyon which
was also on the pod race route this is
also where luke and biggs would fly
their t-16s luke at that speed would be
able to plug in time it's just like
beggar's canyon back home he even passes
the same ramp that anakin steered up to
leapfrog sabolba the gate of that ramp
is still busted he clears the atmosphere
and speed past that rhodium kit on the
starliner but this alerts the new
republic x-wings the elder one is
captain carson tiva played by paul sun
hung lee who's showed up a few times a
season to the mandalorian and he even
remembers mano's voice and references
those events but the younger lieutenant
is played by max lloyd jones who played
the standard of luke skywalker in the
mandalorian season 2 finale amanda
returns to pele how was it
wizard ah the same word for awesome used
by anakin's friend kitster in phantom
minutes this is so wizarding infinix and
greets him offering him credits to help
boba fett but mando offers to help him
for free but first i gotta pay a visit
to a little friend but will groggoo be
too changed to greet mando warmly well
man don't need to
grow from that jedi cult we'll find out
next time on the mandalore
we'll find out next time on the
mandalorian
i mean this is still his show right hey
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at new york
starsmerch.com follow me on instagram
and twitter at ea boss follow new
rockstars and subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you